all right chief meteorologist ted
florento the perfect wintry weather
pretty much everyone at the station has
been to enchant it's gorgeous out there
of course we had the big fundraiser last
night this is a photo check that picture
out of my daughter mia and our golden
doodle bella we were out the night that
they let dogs come out and oh my gosh
that was so much fun to see everybody
with their pooches it's so great you
guys look amazing oh well thanks
christine we had a great time
i feel like she wasn't really uh digging
the picture there
i got a question so how did you get
kirsten to stay still for the shot
because i'm always moving around you
mean
you stink are you
this was closed yesterday because of all
the strong winds but now it's back open
and maybe kj will make another
appearance down there
it's so far
check it out
everything and then brian you guys did
the ice skating right
the ice skating was a blast
brian going around
the you know the ice skating rink
fast like he does when he drives it's
just going as fast as he can
another live look outside this isn't a
painting look at this look how nice this
is so much drama with the sunset
yesterday we couldn't see anything at
all because we had those low clouds now
those clouds are out there but giving us
a fantastic sunset outside new
neighborhoods to show you 46 in centenni
hills along with sky canyon 49 for north
las vegas and we're 52 sunrise manor 51
for whitney ranch and mountain's edge at
47 degrees and guys i got to show you
this you guys see this we wanted to
pinpoint it look there's our elf a
little elf on the shelf right there had
to bring it in we'll put him around the
studio all right outside the valley 43
for uh pram 43 also boulder city
laughlin you're coming in right now at a
very chilly 51 degrees skies mainly
clear we had some high clouds these thin
clouds right there just pass through
but now we're going to get some clearing
over now that's going to allow the
temperatures to really
drop rapidly back to freezing or just
below freezing we have another system
out in the pacific but this time this is
going to track to the north all we'll
see from this are some north winds that
we'll get on friday futurecast shows
that system staying to the north nothing
here except those winds next week though
we'll have another system tickets aim at
the west coast this will bring us
additional cloud cover futurecast not
really giving us big chances for showers
next week but we'll see if that change
changes for us because remember it is
only wednesday as we get closer to that
event the forecast evolves we'll see if
that will bring us any more rainfall for
next week we're hoping so so i promise
you i'd show you overnight lows here are
your neighborhoods look at that some of
you dropping below freezing anthem
southern highlands of freezing 29 in
somewhere below freeze it right below
freezing for centenni hills and aliante
the outskirts of town nellis maybe even
out there near sunrise manor too 26 only
for prop 32 at the freezing mark for
boulder city bundle up tomorrow morning
for sure clear skies tonight
temperatures in the morning in those 30s
49 are high tomorrow and that is it we
should be at 56 for this time of the
year so not just tomorrow we have
several days of highs staying chilly and
overnight lows staying cold next week
there's those shower chances back again
that means more snow in the mountains
back to you